-Jeff, wonderful to see you.
How are you?
-It's very wonderful
to see you, Seth.
I am...good,
everything considered, you know.
My heart goes out to all those
who are not so fortunate,
of course,
but, for now, we're okay.
I'm here with my family
in England.
We're shootin'
that "Jurassic World" movi
and they've put their hear
and soul into the protocol
and we're safe and having
a creative blast, you know
-That's really nice.
You were one of the first
productions to go back,
the new "Jurassic Park" film
And I think one of the thing
that was nice is not just
the safety protocols
you were talking about,
but this is the first time
that you and Sam Neill
and Laura Dern
have been together
for 30 years, correct?
-Yes, yes!
That's right.
Our characters, certainly,
oh, we've been in touch
here and there.
-Yeah.
-But that's right.
Our characters,
Sam Neill's character
and Laura Dern,
we're back together.
Colin Trevorrow,
great writer-director,
is directing it.
He's fantastic.
But, of course,
Chris Pratt is in it,
Bryce Dallas Howard,
and Mamoudou Athie,
DeWanda Wise,
BD Wong, Justice Smith.
There's a whole coterie
of luminaries.
-[ Laughs ]
How do your children --
I know we have kids
that are of similar age.
Are they enjoying
England, so far?
-Well, they are!
They are.
Of course,
we have a very special
view of it right here,
but this is a great place.
They love it.
I'm around all the time.
-Yeah.
-And Emilie's mom
is here, actually,
and so we've got lotsa --
It's very cozy.
And they're havin' a good time
They're doin' all kinda --
They're just --
They're loving it.
They feed the ducks.
They touch cows.
They were kind of -- Seth.
They feed donkeys.
They're good.
-That's wonderful to hear.
-I have a piano in my room
and Charlie's taking
piano lessons -- had been --
but I'm taking him through
Not only do I do
my piano homework,
but I'm taking him through his
Suzuki lesson every day.
He's proceeding apace.
-Now, tell me,
how young were you
when you started,
when you got your first lesson
-I think, as I remembered,
ten-ish or nine-ish, or ten-ish.
He's, for heaven's sakes, five
He's way ahead of me.
Not to mention the bicycle
I think around the same
time, ten,
I started get on the bike.
He's whizzing around, you know
They're most precocious.
-And is he taking to the piano
Do you feel like he has
a natural skill for it?
-Well, who knows?
I don't think he's
any Mozart, but --
There's no indication
of that, yet.
But he's kinda like me,
disciplined.
It's around all the time.
He sees me playing all the time,
so he likes to check in.
We go through the stuff
and I'll be darned if he isn't
you know, playing a bunch
of stuff! You know.
It's thrilling for me.
-That's amazing.
-It's sometimes maddening
for me, too.
I'm very kind of, around piano
I get very [ Strikes hands ]
kind of, you know,
I'm not like the father
in "Shine."
I'm not, you know, a maniac.
I'm not gonna, you know, but..
[ Laughter ]
But I'm, you know, "Focus now.
I want him to be focused.
I'm a little tough,
but, you know,
I think it's good.
He's taking to it, yeah.
He's doing okay.
The other one -- the other one
is taking little lessons.
River is taking lessons.
Horrible, horrible.
He comes in and all
I'm supposed to do is,
if he doesn't do anything,
which he doesn't,
is take his fingers
like a puppet
and push them against the thing.
I play "Twinkle Twinkle
Little Star" every day
with his right hand,
his left hand,
as he's moaning and stuff,
and I just kinda do it.
He says, "Do it quick,
as quick as you can,"
'cause afterwards,
we give him Gummy Bears.
So that's what he likes.
-Oh, well, there you go.
You have to reward them,
somehow.
I'd also like to say we've
been doing this show --
you know, we've done more
than a thousand of these
and you're the first perso
to reference
the father in "Shine."
And I really appreciate
'cause I feel like
that's a cultural referenc
we've lost over the years.
[ Laughing ]
-Oh, yeah, no.
We have to appeal to the kids.
They love that "Shine"
stuff, yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
-Call me a panderer,
but I don't care, you know
-Yeah, you like to play
to your teen base.
Hey, I wanna ask about this.
I imagine one of the things --
again, it was
groundbreaking tech
in the first
"Jurassic Park" film
that, now, must seem
incredibly dated,
and I think
you must look back.
They were actually
pretty dangerous,
the early T. rexes, yes?
-I know what you're
talking about.
Well, not really.
There's no such thing
as dinosaurs.
-[ Laughing ]
-But, yes, it was
dangerous back then.
The -- [ Laughs ]
I hate to be the one
to break it to you, you know
-No, somebody had to.
-Yeah, there's no Easter Bunny
either. No Easter Bunny.
-Aw, man.
-But, yeah, in the first one
Steven Spielberg,
if I can invoke his name,
was off-screen going,
"Rawr! Rawr!
Everybody look at the
tennis ball. Rawr! Rawr!"
In this one, you know,
they have sound effects,
so you hear dinosaurs.
And they've got
the big dinosaurs
and it's great, you know.
But Stan Winston had,
back then,
won the Oscar for what he did.
But, they were new,
they were groundbreaking
and, on occasion,
there was T. rex
that was life-size,
that, when you went into the
sound stage, they said,
"Don't go anywhere near it
because it can get
kind of --"
and we're still trying
to figure out how
to operate it.
So it can go into kinda
unexpected convulsions
and [ Strikes palm ]
drop on you or attack you
or it gets, you know.
We didn't wanna get killed
by the fake T. rex,
so, you know.
-Yeah, that would've been --
certainly would've made
the press junket a lot harder,
if one of you had died
via the mechanical T. rex.
-It would've been dour.
-[ Laughing ]
-It would've been dark days.